这个不是M码
就是L号
反正不是很大
当然是袖子有点长
我穿了
你看我肚子大
这个正好能够着
应该是M码槽的
9块
这个袖子长
我的胳膊短
穿哪个都袖子长
9块
来这一块
这个是个黑色
后半边松紧的这一条
黑色夏天穿的这一条裤
刚刚裤头一个白色
现在又出来一个黑色
两边有些扎痘
来腰围66
能拉伸84
66 84
平围102116
单长37
裤长488
这个9块扣个8
9块扣8
特别软很薄
夏天穿的特别丝滑
这个
9块9块扣8扣8
9块扣个8扣个8
9块钱扣个8
来这个卫衣
这个大卫衣男生可以穿
男女都可以穿的
后面
就是有交印图案的
来胸围
胸围134
134哦
到140
长度是71
这个9块扣个1
9块9块扣一扣一
9块扣个一
这个是个S码
就s码呢
这个卫衣里面是毛圈的都是毛圈的
就是毛圈的
前面是卫衣的
卫衣里面是毛圈的都是毛圈的
前面有胶印图案
后背是光板的
就是水印
有的是水印
有的是胶印
来这个胸围
胸围106
长度66
来这个9块
扣6扣6
9块钱9块钱
扣个6
9块9块
扣6扣6
来这个S
威灵威灵
这个是一个这样的一个上衣
然后这个袖子的话是一个中袖
藏蓝色
来胸围
胸围是
长度59
这个原来是29的
这个9块扣1扣1
9块扣个1
后面的话是可以
打杆的
后面是
这个29的
29的
给你们9块
9块扣1扣1
9元扣个1
孤品孤品
9块扣1
姐帮忙看一下264
再补
在不在
你没收到
我给你看看去
今天给你发过了没有
你看看
-
没有
没有没有
是不是给你发走了
你没收到
264不在
没有
跑单里面也没有
跑单我也看了那几件里面没有
没有没有
你问一下客服
联系客服
问一下明明姐发了没
你问一下
问一下她
问一下明明上次不知道是谁发的
一件绿色长袖
你问问她
她现在没在这里发货
今天发了发好就走了
11点多走的
来这一款
灰色一条小脚的一条裤
来
腰围70 72
腿围腿围1106
当场34
裤长裤长99
这个9块
扣个9扣个9
9块钱扣9扣9
这一款
9块扣9扣9
来
这一款
这个是一个小西装
黑色的一款小西装
小西装
胸围106106116106116的胸围
长度是75
长度75
来这个29扣5
29块扣5扣5
黑色黑色黑色的一个西装
来这个均码
这个牌均码
来蓝白条的一款棉混纺的这个短袖
来胸围
胸围102108
102108长度71
这个9块扣个1
这个9块9块扣1扣1
微领微领这一件
底牙拼接的一点蕾丝
这样一个拼接9块
9块扣个1
来这一款
这个是直筒的
直筒的一条灰色
灰色一条裤
腰尾
腰尾70 72
70 72
腿尾
腿尾94 108
当长34
裤长是100
来这个9块
9块扣8
这个牌这是啥牌子
9块9块扣8扣8
面料很软
面料是一个棉97圈是3
棉97圈是3
面料是一个很垂
棉97的
薄的很
版型也好
这个9块9块扣个3
9块扣个3
棉75巨扎25
棉75巨扎25扣8来给你了
376无关心动
腰尾多少
腿尾多少给你了
你再过一层
来这一个
腰尾的话
平铺是70
72 74
最多到76
腿尾
腿尾94到112
当长34
裤长是100
能穿吗
无关心动
这里是有风机裤
有个风机裤
然后这里有个裤子
里面是拉链
鸭子拉链
能穿不
没有没有送你呢哦
这样子的
没有送你呢
尺寸你合适不
无关心动可以吗
哎呦哎呦
牌子掉了
牌子烂了
给我擦一下
面料很舒服
棉97捐质3
okok
没问题
可以是吧
好点
那你给花了376
来解图
刚刚还有一条灰色小脚
推荐哪条
还有一条灰色小脚的
这个比较好
面料
如果现在穿的话
这个比较凉快
这个比较瘦
版型也是这个好看
那个也是9块
是不是这个
但是面料没这个舒服
给你实话实说
没这个舒服
又软又薄
这个话就是春秋的时候
你可以
如果现在的话就有点热
我感觉
这个感觉是含毛的那种
里面都有内衬
这个现在的话不能穿
这里面有一层内衬
这个含毛的
如果是现在穿的话
还是这个比较好
然后面料也好它
如果是我选的话
我就会选这一条
现在穿面料又薄又软
如果
各有各的好
那个春秋天时候穿好
含毛的里面有一层内衬
OK
谢谢
大家
看
我 67 了
你看
发这头
consumer
glossy
Brooks
你能够看
你看
这个
还有这个
这里面这个
这个
还有这个
可以不可以就给你了
这个要比那个厚厚一点点
OK
这个汉毛377
来9块377
来377
都得穿皮带
66都得穿皮带
这个这个没有送你
这个应该差不多
OK
这版型都好
版型都好
来这一款
这个是
花包腰的一个蓝色牛仔裤
小角的一条哈林裤
来腰尾
腰尾66能拉伸到84
平尾104
当长39
裤长是100
来这个39
39块
这个是29
花包腰全送你了
这一条
这个29
这个又出来一条
看看
36码
这个和刚刚那个灰色是一个版型
Nobel-Level-i-wery彩色
有 invece
человек
腰尾
腰尾的话是70
аче Nude
dec stopped
100元
3醒
可可9
家懐
1900木
合法
완aires
你看这个灰 这个是个黑
9块
9块9块 来这一条
这个是一个休闲的一个外套
连帽的 连帽的
这个是蓝色拼接一个黑色
这样的一个休闲外套
新款
胸围110 112
长度 长度68
长度68
来这个39扣8
这个底下是有腰
是有那个松紧的
腰上有松紧
前面有小小拉链
来这个39 39扣8扣8
放蓝色的 放蓝色的
来这一款
这个是连帽的一款
蓝色蓝色的一个外套
前面有一排扣
啊不对
前面是个拉链
胸围
腰
112130长度64
来这个19 19扣1
19 19扣1扣1
两边有写扎口袋的
这个是这种
毛绿绿的
大家每次这种毛绿绿的
这个小外套
面料很软
来这个19块给你们
扣1扣1
19 19
来这一款
军绿色
军绿色的这一款
点一圈